foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar em ice
workflows in every direction
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Lico Leica Microsystems to learn more
visit Leica microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Seth
Villarreal Advanced workflow specialist
nanotechnology Leica Microsystems Seth
you may now begin your presentation
welcome to this presentation on the emis
my name is Seth Villarreal I'm an
advanced workflow specialist for Leica
Microsystems
this presentation will be covering
the wide variety of workflows that the
emis supports or is a direct part of
the emis is a high pressure freezer
this enables
a number of different ways of working
with samples that are all preserved
by vitrifying them through high pressure
freezing
in brief high pressure freezing
as the name might suggest uses high
pressure
under short couple hundred milliseconds
to limit the formation of ice crystals
as the sample is very rapidly cooled in
order to vitrify the sample and preserve
it in this
static fashion allowing subsequent
processing
and cryo workflows
unlike plunge freezing that tends to
work with extremely small volumes
emis works with slightly larger volumes
in ranges of three to six millimeters
wide and
generally 100 to 300 microns deep
the sample carriers allow much thicker
and wider samples to be preserved by
vitrification
these volumes ranging
several microliters in this size
are
high pressure Frozen
as controlled through the software and
Hardware of the emis
the software
carries out all the internal functions
of a freezing process but a user does
need to prepare the sample for the ice
to then take over
the emiss uses a cartridge system
a fully assembled cartridge on the left
of this most recent image is a cylinder
there are
an upper and lower
cylinder halves as well as a middle
plate
these three components
serve to hold the sample in X Y and Z
preventing it from moving it around
while still allowing it to be high
pressure Frozen
in the center of the middle plate
there's a small hole this is where the
sample sits
generally samples
are enclosed
within a small carrier
there are wide varieties of assembling
the sample
and I will cover these in brief as it
comes up
all the samples are contained
within an assembled sandwich that fits
within the hole of the middle plate
as part of assembling the cartridge
so
here are the workflows that I'll be
covering in this presentation
some of these occur before
some during the process of high pressure
freezing
and many of them
take a high pressure Frozen sample
and modify it further in order to get
the desired data
I'll be starting
at the beginning
looking at ways of preparing a sample
and collecting data before going to the
emis
the coral life is a workflow that starts
with live samples that are imaged
a wide field microscope and then very
rapidly transferred to the emis allowing
preservation the sample
and making use of
the light microscopy information
in order to capture a particular moment
of interest for subsequent analysis by
em
the Thunder imager Nano is particular
wide field microscope
part that is part of this workflow
it uses specialized sampling Chambers
which are
dedicated
in this workflow
and holding the sample
notice that
there is both an in and out port
for gas exchange and you may also be
able to see the black middle plate on
the bottom of the sampling chamber
visible through the transparent top
such that the sample is held in the
middle plate ready to go to the emi's at
a moment's notice
this allows Imaging of a sample
over a period of time maintaining the
sample in appropriate atmosphere and
temperature
and once the sample is fully imaged such
that either a biological process is
completed
or a particular transient biological
process is located
the sample can be transferred to the
emis
with this sampling chamber allowing the
very rapid assembly of a complete
uh cartridge such that it can be
Frozen
within five seconds of
the transfer off the Thunder imager Nano
in this process the sampling chamber is
picked up out of the microscope
placed on
the work area of the ice
and then in three simple motions
the first sliding the sampling chamber
up to disconnect the middle plate
from the chamber
followed by closing
a specially designed lever arm
to seal the sample within the middle
plate before closing the lid of the emis
completing the overall
cartridge assembly
to show this at speed
here is a brief video
the sampling chamber placed on top of
the EM ice
middle plate removed
covering the sample and completing the
cartridge
five seconds
from Imaging
to Frozen
this process
allows
live cell Imaging as well as benefiting
from the blur removal
of the Thunder software
then the sample after high pressure
freezing
could for example undergo free
substitution and resin embedding
subsequent ultramarcotomy and Tam
Imaging can make use of the coordinates
and visual information from White
microscopy
in order to identify
the particular cell
and make use of the tem ultrastructural
information in combination
as a correlative workflow to examine
points in time
with a high degree of accuracy
one separate note on this process
high pressure freezing
cannot make use of glass cover slips as
a glass is too delicate
the light microscope relies upon a
sapphire corrected objective as the
sapphire discs are capable of surviving
the high pressure freezing process
the coral life workflow is designed in
totality to make use of all these
individual capabilities into an overall
workflow
coming back to this overview slide
there are
capabilities of the ice that happen
during the freezing process
I'll be starting with light stimulation
light stimulation
allows the use of optogenetics and other
similar workflows
directly within the freezing chamber
of the Amis
the ice freezing chamber has a small
Sapphire window allowing illumination by
a light module
as controlled by the software of the
emis
various single length wavelength modules
with programmable intensity and timing
allows precise
stimulation of a sample
during an experiment
unlike the metal carriers that are very
common
stimulating a sample
via light requires a transparent surface
just like the sapphire discs
being requirement in the coral life
workflow they remain a requirement in
light stimulation
the sample must go through the emis
with a visually transparent
cartridge and
the sapphire disc to allow the light to
reach the sample
the sapphire discs are stacked with
spacers to create the correct height as
supported by the middle plate
and then the cartridge halves are
transparent to allow the light passing
through the freezing chamber to reach
the sample
with the process of light stimulation
there can be a period
of equilibration in dark phase and then
a defined set of pulses
in order to achieve particular targets
of stimulation
as well as time intervals after
stimulation to look at different points
in time
in a
triggered biological process
in this example vesicle recovery
after stimulation
shows different time points at a
membrane recovery after vesicle release
infusion
there is one other
workflow I should touch on that occurs
during the process of high pressure
freezing
and this is electrical stimulation
like
Optical stimulation applying
an electric field to a sample
especially neurons can allow examination
of
vesicle activity or other functions of a
cell
in order to look at
different aspects of their biology
in this case instead of vesicle recovery
this is looking at vesicle Fusion to the
cell membrane
in an even more complicated way compared
to light stimulation
electrical stimulation
requires
the charge
and program to travel with the cartridge
into the freezing chamber due to the
energetic
aspects of high pressure freezing
it is infeasible to
have the sample wired up
external to the freezing chamber so a
specially designed middle plate
brings the energy needed
in terms of a banking small very small
capacitors
and a very small computer
all of this is triggered by a photo
sensor bypassing the physical connection
that might otherwise be needed
using a light module
the photo sensor on this middle plate is
triggered and it carries out the
programmed stimulation
this program stimulation can be complex
or simple
either single ongoing or interval
stimulation in order to carry out an
experiment
both of these workflows light and
electrical stimulation are compatible it
is feasible to
both light stimulate a sample as well as
electrically stimulated within the same
option
after you have a sample
which is to say it's been preserved by
high pressure freezing and is now a
static snapshot of the particular state
there are a wide variety of ways to work
with the sample
I've mentioned one of them free
substitution and then going to
ultramicrodomy and Tem
I'm going to be looking at
a number of these workflows together as
they are related
techniques
allowing benefit of looking at
the revealed layers by Ultraman economy
within a sample
free substitution
takes a vitrified cryosample
and brings it back up to room
temperature in a process that dissolves
the water
without it crystallizing such that
you can
replace it with resin and turn what is a
vitreous sample
into a solid resin suitable for
sectioning on an ultra microtome and
then collection collecting those
sections
and going to a Tem
simply
cutting sectioning staining Imaging
can provide
enormous insight
into what is happening within a sample
but
from that process there are ways of
expanding that workflow
that I consider worth special note in
the context of this presentation
the first is
immunostaving
this requires the preservation of
structure
often all the way down to protein
structure and allows
antibody labeling
either with gold Tags by itself or with
silver amplification
in order to look at
single areas of Interest
by antibody labeling
on electron microscope
in this particular sample a knockout
Mouse
is amino labeled
at cx43
and then the gold nanoparticles attached
to that antibody
undergo silver application to make it
easier to image
immunostatin can enable picking out
individual areas of Interest
fluorescent labeling is a much easier
process
in many respects
with fluorescent information
that is
cross-reference to the
electron microscopy analysis can take
the best of both worlds in many respects
while fluorescent labeling is easier
in a lot of ways
and also more common
preserving fluorescence
through embedding is often difficult
hence the benefit of Imaging before high
pressure freezing and resin embedding
but
there are established protocols
for this process to preserve
fluorescence all the way through
resin embedding allowing direct Imaging
of that fluorescence
within the resin embedded sample
this particular image
is looking at
a heck 293 T cell
with fluorescently labeled
epha2 with M Venus
you can see the fluorescence surrounding
the nucleus
as well as
a particular area
blown up in Greater Image
and
the localization to different parts of
the internal structure of the cell
there are
a couple different ways of working with
a vitrified sample
under continuing cryo conditions
cryofib and freeze fracture are both
ways
of maintaining the sample
under cryo conditions and looking at the
internal structure
freeze fracture
is the process
of vitrifying a sample
taking the specially designed carriers
and opening them up such that the
internals of the sample is exposed
in a vitreous preserve sample
when is mechanically separated it tends
to fracture along lipid bilayers
allowing the direct Imaging
of
proteins
Crossing
the players
in this case this image shows
pre-fractured intestinal cells
presenting very
images of microvilli at the brush border
as well as some images of mitochondria
and plasma membrane
between two adjacent cells
freeze fracture is decades old at this
point but remains a very well
established method of looking at the
internals of a cell and their interfaces
a very similar technique to freeze
fracture
is using a focused ion beam to Mill Away
part of a sample
this also exposes the internal structure
when Imaging a sample
light can penetrate very effectively
through transparent tissue
after high pressure freezing seeing the
inside of it
is difficult the sample needs to be
exposed
freeze fracture ultramarotomy these
techniques
remove surface the sample in the general
area
in contrast
with correlative techniques or other
information
knowledge of where precisely in a sample
a particular region of interest is
located
allows the use of a fib to remove
surrounding material
exposing a thin lamella of the area of
Interest
in the set of images on the right
fluorescence information from the top
figure shows some areas of Interest
in a c elegans worm
portions of that worm are imaged in
detail B
after freezing
that area can be examined
by electromicroscopy
in D
that area can be exposed
with the FIB beam
subsequently
e through h
shows lift out in which the lamella is
removed and presented
for tem Imaging
the lower figure
shows that Imaging
in this sample
the areas of Interest
were the rapisms it is
a variety of
targets both
looking at individual ribosomal
translation translocation States
as well as some of the cell to cell
variation in ribosome structure
overall the use of a fib
enables a great deal of Versatility in
how the sample is exposed but it does
require targeting
the comparatively very large
vitrified volume
of a high pressure Frozen sample
does mean that fit techniques need to be
carefully considered
and looking for particular regions of
Interest
still
despite that caveat it can be a very
Illuminating technique in looking at
a particular aspect of interest within
an overall sample
the last workflow that I'll be talking
about is samovis
samovis stands for
cryoelectromicroscopy of vitreous
sections
in a very similar fashion
sectioning of a resin embedded sample at
room temperature
samovas is the sectioning
of a cryo sample at cryo temperatures
maintaining it in its native state
without any substitution
cryo Ultra necrootomy
is both a difficult and rewarding
technique that can allow you to image a
sample
without
any chemical modification
the sample is preserved
high pressure freezing
sectioned
and then those sections are imaged
in this particular image a brand
negative bacteria
this is
what the bacteria looks like
and that's it
the
peptic
dog like and layer
is shown
as well as
the plasma membrane
these sections
these vitreous sections
are quite fragile
but
with skill they show the sample
in a fully native state
simply vitrified to capture that
particular moment
foreign
all of these workflows
they work
not all at once but they come together
to offer
a large variety of options
to go through the emis and end up
where the sample is best suited for
subsequent Imaging
starting with live cells carrying out
any appropriate Imaging
high pressure freezing on the emis
any light or electrical stimulation on
those images as appropriate
and then taking that vitrified sample
and proceeding through the variety of
cryo
or room temperature workflows to end up
on electron microscope and collect
the appropriate information
from the goals of the Imaging
thank you for listening our presentation
I hope this was informative and useful
please reach out to Leica macrosystems
if we can help further
in your process
thank you for your time
thank you Seth for your informative
presentation
if if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
why are different types of carriers used
well
generally uh
a couple of reasons one kind of
historical just
as the volume for which high pressure
freezing could be successfully
implemented expanded so do the volume of
the carriers to work with larger samples
in any particular moment now or in the
past the shape of the carrier used
generally was chosen based on how to
work with the samples
in samovas for example copper tube
freezing
is a particular way of presenting a
sample that is a small volume but useful
for sectioning whereas in freeze
fracture a
more spherical sample is often
beneficial
in all cases the physics of high
pressure freezing remains unchanged it's
just how the sample is presented and
handled
that affects the shape chosen
great thank you our next question asks
are Sapphire discs only necessary for
light microscopy workflows
necessary is a bit of a strong word
Sapphire discs are necessary for light
microscopy workflows they are
occasionally very beneficial in
unusual circumstances in other workflows
generally for cells that are just
very delicate or very contrary and
despite any coatings on the metal
carriers the cells in questions refuse
to grow the inert material of the
sapphire disc is sometimes a last resort
despite its greater cost for getting
cells to behave and grow more normally
then asks how does the ice switch
between these different workflows
the cartridge system means that
any particular carrier shape can be done
without any changes to the ice you could
do a freeze fracture system a sapphire
disc
Flem experiment or copper tube freezing
or regular carrier freezing
all in the same session
so
if it is only a question of how the
sample is fed into the ice
generally speaking you can swap
basically at will
for the light stimulation and electrical
stimulation there is some Hardware
changes which take swapping of
oh
about three to ten minutes it's very
short for the light modules to just
remove and swap a plug
on the front of the machine the
electrical stimulation uses a small
plate in the front which
takes about five or ten minutes to swap
out
the
sampling Chambers
use an involved apparatus that is
longer to install on Leica service side
but still relatively straightforward to
swap out
it takes also about 10 minutes so it
would not be appropriate trying to do
any kind of uh live cell rapid timing
workflow in part of other samples but
you can swap between them
in the same day back and forth quite
easily
thank you Seth our next question is how
many samples can it do
well for any particular day I would say
that the limitations have in my
experience always been on how many
samples can you prepare
so the ice can freeze a sample roughly
every two minutes
so you can freeze quite a lot in any
single session the ice is designed to
freeze
in three groups
of triplicates
so nine samples in a batch
and you can uh
do as many as you have
in that time rate
for the overall lifespan of the machine
it is recommended that you get it
serviced about every uh 1500
shots of freezings of a sample
and that takes most users I've worked
with
a couple years or more to get to
generally batches are around 9 to 27.
samples in a session
great thank you our next question asks
using this system do you see any
crystalline ice or is it all vitrified
what kind of pressures do you use to
achieve this state and do you use any
crypto protective agents such as DMSO
during cooling or just cool as it comes
okay a few few different questions in
there
[Music]
um
the the answer
all of them kind of at once is yes
the pressures that we use to that we
work in with high pressure freezing is
around 2200 bar
there are some
very carefully done studies suggesting
that the ideal range is
between
2000 and 2400 bar for which the
particular cell type can cause some
shifting in the ideal pressure 2200 bar
is
the most common successful pressure
for the samples that I've observed
now
um
that ties into the other part about is
it is the sample entirely vitrified
generally speaking it is
dependent on how thick you're trying to
work the sample into the ice the depth
of freezing is usually
the
main factor
in initial tests of most samples so you
might see good freezing for a cell
monolayer
100 microns depth great freezing all the
way through it
if you use deeper carriers say 300
microns
you would very likely in that same
sample see great freezing at the surface
and then progressively lower quality
freezing as you get deeper into it
for looking at tissues and such it can
be very important to get good
restrication all the way through the
full depth of the tissue and so
cryoprotective agents are often used and
they vary based on
how the tissue would be physiologically
affected by the
crowd protectant um
for example when I was just starting out
I came across a reference
um High molarity sugar water is a great
cryoprotectant it does it is very hard
to crystallize that water get high
pressure freezing and it you will not
get any
crystalline ice
in that water part of it
after I tried it a couple times and then
went back to the library I found out
perhaps very obviously to many people in
the audience very high concentrations of
sugar will completely mess up the cells
in the sample so crap protectants such
as DMSO two methylpentane
and others are all chosen based on
ensuring the sample will not be affected
a
general rule of thumb most broadly
speaking is the less water you have
surrounding the sample
the better off you'll be for avoiding
water crystals
I hesitate to make a direct
recommendation of any particular
cryoprotectant
they
the performance of them is often
dependent on the sample and so usually
as I've experienced myself
some time in the library will give a
better recommendation than trying to
experiment with the full breadth of
possible options
thank you it looks like we have one more
question here and it says I have a
number of colleagues that are interested
in high pressure freezing and I would
like to share this presentation with
them is there a recording available for
sharing
uh yes this is an on-demand webinar so
the link to this page will let anybody
view it again
they're if there is an interest in the
slides of this presentation I'm afraid
you would have to uh directly reach out
to me this is something we will not be
Distributing on demand though it will be
available through discussion is probably
the best way to put it
yes thank you Seth for answering those
questions for our audience today do you
have any final comments
um
by all means reach out to me have my
email address it's
seth.vilreal at Leica Dash
microsystems.com I I'll put that
in the next version this presentation
written somewhere and
thank you for your attention
yes thank you again Seth for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Leica Microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye